y
[Música]
el mundo superó los 25 millones de casos
por kobe 19 de acuerdo al conteo de la
universidad johns hopkins en américa
latina' la pandemia no da tregua y
brasilia cuenta más de 120 mil muertos
por la enfermedad mientras que india
reportó un nuevo récord mundial de casos
en 24 horas con casi 79 mil
vuelve la violencia aportan oregón un
hombre falleció tras recibir un disparo
en el pecho cuando manifestantes a favor
del presidente tronco chocaron con
activistas del grupo black la eps marina
también hubo protestas contra el racismo
en kenosha donde el afroamericano jake
blake fue baleado por la espalda por un
policía trompo prometió visitar la
ciudad este martes
y los migrantes a bordo del barco
humanitario financiado por el artista
urbano banks y fueron ya transferidos a
otras embarcaciones tras recibir ayuda
de la guardia costera italiana y de la
ong alemanas y gouache el louis michel
la había pedido ayuda durante horas sin
recibir respuesta
una feliz mañana de domingo mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24 vamos a iniciar
este informativo con la actualización de
las cifras hay que dejar la pandemia a
nivel global el mundo ya superó los 25
millones de contagios los fallecidos
ascienden a más de 800 42.000 y los
recuperados ya son más de 16 millones de
438.000
y es que la pandemia sigue golpeando con
fuerza a américa latina brasil superó
este sábado los 120.000 muertos por kobe
19 sin embargo las cifras de los
fallecidos y de los contagios han
comenzado a estabilizarse en los últimos
días el presidente ya el bolsón aro
volvió a defender el uso de la
cloroquina como un tratamiento contra
este virus y nuevamente fue visto sin
mascarilla protectora y estrechando la
mano de decenas de seguidores vamos a
ver el informe preparado por andrés meza
muñoz
brasil superó los 120 mil muertos por
kobe 19 y el número de contagios se
acerca a los 4 millones aunque las
cifras diarias han empezado a
estabilizarse en medio de este panorama
el presidente yair bolsonaro quien
padeció y ya superó el virus continúa
promoviendo las aglomeraciones durante
su visita al estado de goiás al
mandatario se le vio sin mascarilla y
estrechando la mano de sus seguidores en
esta ocasión volvió a defender el uso de
la cloroquina como tratamiento contra el
coronavirus aunque su eficacia no ha
sido comprobada el pulso entre su
administración y los gobiernos estatales
no se detiene
sigue negando que el virus es grave que
no es una pandemia que necesitamos usar
mascarilla promueve la aglomeración no
usa desinfectante de manos no hace
ninguna recomendación de distanciamiento
condena el aislamiento e incluso
promueve la hidroxi cloroquina illinois
lo lamento
y hay una promo de cloroquina sao paulo
es el listado más golpeado por el cobe
19 en brasil su gobernador dijo que
están listos para garantizar la vacuna
en este territorio en caso de que el
gobierno dé bolsonaro les dé la espalda
con miles de voluntarios en este y otros
estados brasil también se ha convertido
en un epicentro mundial de ensayos de
vacunas entre ellas las fabricadas por
la universidad de oxford y astrazéneca
así como la desarrollada por la alemana
bio en tec y la estadounidense para ser
por otro lado india registró un recorte
diario de nuevos casos de contagio
fueron en total es 78 mil 761 los
positivos registrados en ese país en las
últimas 24 horas esto supone también un
nuevo récord mundial para un solo día
anteriormente dicha marca la tenía de
eeuu que a mediados de julio había
reportado 77 mil 300 la nación de más de
300 millones de habitantes tiene más de
35 millones de casos confirmados de kobe
[Música]
cambiamos de tema y pasamos a eeuu un
país es sacudido por un nuevo hecho de
violencia en medio de una oleada de
protestas contra el racismo en la ciudad
de portland en el estado de oregón un
hombre blanco recibió un disparo en el
pecho aunque no se ha confirmado que
este hecho esté directamente ligado a
las protestas el sábado en la noche
grupos afines al presidente de donald
trump se enfrentaron con activistas de
blacklight smara el fallecido portaba
una gorra de patriot player un grupo de
extrema derecha mientras tanto en
kenosha wisconsin en ciudades en la que
el afroamericano jake blake quedó
paralizado de la cintura para abajo tras
ser baleado en la espalda por un policía
continuaron las protestas contra el
racismo sistémico lideradas por su
familia desde texas donde donald trump
visitaba a los afectados y veía los
estragos causados por el huracán laura
el mandatario prometió visitar que no
sea este martes
y probablemente hemos tenido un éxito
tremendo finalmente obtuvimos la luz
verde por parte de las autoridades para
enviar a la guardia nacional
en cuestión de minutos con la guardia
todo el mundo se fue y la situación
estuvo segura
masnoticias en france 24 todos los
migrantes a bordo de la embarcación
humanitaria financiada por el artista
banks y que había quedado varado en el
mediterráneo' fueron transferidos a
otros barcos los más vulnerables fueron
evacuados por la guardia costera
italiana y los demás se pasaron algo que
humanitarios y watch 4 el informe es de
aurora bellos
los mensajes de auxilio de louis michel
el barco financiado por el artista
británico banksy fueran finalmente
escuchados una guardia costera italiana
acudió al rescate de 49 de las personas
más vulnerables el sábado y el resto de
los migrantes a bordo unas 150 personas
fueron recibidos por un barco de la ong
alemanas y watch y la organización
médicos sin fronteras están esperando a
bordo del numeral sy watch para que se
les asigne un lugar seguro numeral louis
michel ya no tiene huéspedes a bordo
pero la lucha de los sobrevivientes no
ha terminado el louis michel de bandera
alemana anunció el viernes que estaba a
barrado y que necesitaba ayuda urgente
después de encontrarse con una
embarcación precaria que transportaba al
menos un migrante muerto si watch 4 que
tiene una clínica a bordo dijo que
decidió actuar ante la falta de reacción
de las autoridades ahora está buscando
un puerto de acogida
para aquellos embarcados más
recientemente la evaluación médica está
en curso con la clínica llena médicos
sin fronteras tratando a las personas
por quemaduras de combustible
deshidratación hipotermia y lesiones
traumáticas los migrantes rescatados
dijeron más tarde que tres personas
habían muerto en el mar antes de la
llegada de louis michel
este año se estima que al menos 300
personas perdieron la vida en el viaje a
través del mediterráneo' para huir de
los conflictos la represión y la pobreza
en áfrica y el oriente medio entre tanto
un barco con unos 450 migrantes fue
rescatado mientras que se encontraba en
peligro de esos obrar por el fuerte
viento y fue escoltado hacia la isla
italiana de lampedusa donde algunos
habitantes salieron a protestar por las
llegadas masivas de las últimas semanas
y es que previamente en las últimas 24
horas habían llegado a lampedusa cerca
de 500 personas repartidas en unas 30
pequeñas embarcaciones esto provocó una
nueva emergencia en el lugar que cuenta
con un centro de acogida para cerca de
200 personas y territorio en el que
ahora
se encuentran asignados al menos un
millar de personas
y en españa al menos cinco incendios
forestales activos han obligado a la
evacuación de más de 2400 personas los
dos focos más importantes están en el
suroeste del país en las regiones
autónomas de andalucía y extremadura las
autoridades calculan que más de nueve
mil hectáreas se han visto afectadas el
informe es de daniela blandón
esto fue lo poco que quedó de un lujoso
complejo hotelero en la costa sur de
españa después de ser devorado por las
llamas en estepona a las afueras de
málaga esta construcción un centro
comercial y decenas de casas tuvieron
que ser evacuados según los vecinos el
fuego se extendió rápidamente por esta
zona de andalucía impulsado por los
fuertes vientos casi cinco minutos
parecía como si le metiera fuego una
bola de papel
como la espuma en cantidad de viento que
él sabe controlado y hace un desastre
con la ayuda de helicópteros y aviones
los bomberos intentan controlar el fuego
provocado por las cada vez más altas
temperaturas de verano de acuerdo con el
gobierno español en los últimos 20 años
se han registrado en promedio 11 mil 500
incendios por año en el país y la
afectación de superficie forestal ha
sido de más de 90 mil hectáreas en
promedio el 2020 no es la excepción en
lo que va del año hasta el 23 de agosto
se han registrado casi 5 mil 600
siniestros aunque la afectación es una
tercera parte más baja de lo que fue en
el mismo lapso de 2019 otra de las
regiones en donde hay más incendios
activos es extremadura sobre todo en el
área conocida como valle del jerte con
incendios que comenzaron en la madrugada
del viernes y avanzan sin control fin
del informativo siga con nosotros y
feliz domingo
[Música]